zone europe bonjour et bienvenue dans
zone europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
bruxelles est réalisée en association
avec tv 78 voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé caroline rousse sera
l'invité de corentin alonso l'occasion
notamment d'évoquer la protection des
animaux pendant le transport la
construction européenne et ses
personnages aux emblématiques nous vous
parlerons de louise weiss cette
française surnommé la grand-mère de
l'europe voyager dans l'assiette
le terroir normand sera à l'honneur nous
vous emmènerons dans l'heure pour vous
faire découvrir la recette d'un an mme
bourget
les expressions populaires à présent
être très connu les français disent être
connu comme le loup blanc
les néerlandais eux disent être reconnu
comme le chien multicolores que dit-on
ailleurs c'est ce que nous verrons à la
fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite saône
robe l'europe dans ma région
je reçois laurent vastel maire de
fontenay-aux-roses pour parler de la
création d'un bioparc à
fontenay-aux-roses bonjour bonjour alors
on va parler comme je le disais de la
création d'un bioparc à
fontenay-aux-roses dans le 92
avant cela est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous rappeler où nous expliquer pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas les
objectifs de valle sud grand paris
territoire donc c'est une association de
11 vivre car en particulier dans les
compétences juridiques qui lui sont
attribuées par la loi
le développement économique est donc
l'une de ses mains de ses objectifs bien
sûr c'est de favoriser la création
d'entreprises sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et alors comment comment est née
justement le projet du bioparc et
comment est ce que vous vous l'avait
accueilli au sein de fontenay aux roses
en fait on l'a même initié à dire
puisque ce projet avec l'homme était
déjà un peu en gestation avant même la
création de vingt déçu devant paris
pourquoi parce que son père aux
particuliers ont ce soir ce que nous
avons à la fois même le cea commissariat
à l'énergie atomique à
fontenay-aux-roses depuis maintenant 70
ans qui a abandonné toutes ces
recherches dans le domaine du nucléaire
et qui en fait a développé tout un pôle
de recherche biomédicale et nous avons
également liée à celle à l'institut de
radioprotection et de sécurité nucléaire
qui aussi sur les effets des radiations
et qui a aussi une importante
implantation quasiment sur le même site
à côté à fontenay aux roses est donc
dans les objectifs du sénat il ya un
transfert de technologie transfert de
compétences et donc il nous paraissait
comme ça a été fait d'ailleurs sur
d'autres compétences notamment dans
l'autre grand secteur comme le laser à
bordeaux de développer un site qui
bénéficie finalement de l' expertise du
ceva et décède en matière de technologie
est ce que le le besoin le plus le plus
flagrant finalement à travers ce projet
c'était de réunir plusieurs plusieurs
entreprises de la santé alors l'idée
c'est de bénéficier de cette opportunité
dans une région ile de france et quand
même fortement axée sur la recherche
biomédicale et beaucoup beaucoup de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques de
recherche biomédicale dans notre région
capitale est donc dans une zone qui est
en plus favorable puisque ni trop
éloignées ni trop proches de paris est
bien desservi de favoriser
l'implantation d'entreprises innovantes
dans le secteur des biotechnologies
c'est-à-dire culture cellulaire puis ce
qui est bio ingénierie moléculaire en
fait qui est l'une des particularités du
ceva aujourd'hui et alors le bioparc
accompagnera donc des entreprises du
secteur de la santé
pourquoi est ce que vous avez décidé
justement de vous concentrer sur ce
secteur et que permettra cette
concentration de ces entreprises sur un
même lieu
justement il ya deux aspects
premièrement pour concentrent des
entreprises sur la même thématique
on a un effet de synergie des
restitutions positif donc ça c'est un
des indes est une des raisons des puits
l'autre c'est que quand on veut faire
est de mettre au point par exemple un
nouvel anticorps qui vint voir telle ou
telle fonction
eh bien il faut faire il faut avoir
accès des plateaux techniques parfois
pour la mise en point notamment certain
nombre de process et qui sont à
l'intérieur
ce qui veut dire que le bio parle de
fontenay aux roses il permet d'avoir
accès aussi aux installations du ce1 et
dsl pour progresser c'est de se dire et
pour avoir une forme de coaching cette
façon sur la mise au point des process
de fabrication est aujourd'hui dans dans
les différentes logiques de voile et sud
grand paris il y à cet enjeu
environnemental alors justement est-ce
que ce projet répond également en ont un
enjeu environnemental et en quoi ils y
répondent il y répond ce sens que il est
bien situé
notamment à côté kazim à quelques mètres
d'un tramway qui permet d'être assez
largement desservi et donc d'être facile
d'accès
c'est son principal avantage
accessoirement les biotechnologies ils
ont par définition une vocation
environnementale aussi bien avec la
crise sanitaire aujourd'hui que la
recherche dans le domaine virologique
bactériologique
ce sont des des recherches qui ont une
utilité en tout cas environnemental et
sur la santé de nos concitoyens et
c'était c'était justement un des
objectifs de deux places et se bioparc à
fontenay-aux-roses c'était par rapport
au transport en commun de faciliter
finalement l'axé grâce aux transports en
commun
l'un des objectifs parce que on était
quand même le principal la principale
opportunité c'était encore une fois
l'existence du commissariat l'énergie a
publié deux fentes de rosa qui permet
aux sites de recherche et donc de créer
autour je dirais humeur un endroit
favorable pour le développement
d'entreprises dans l'abdomen
merci beaucoup laurent vastel d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensations pour plus
d'informations sur le projet on peut se
rendre sur le site vallée sud.fr comme
chaque semaine nous vous faisons
découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction européenne
aujourd'hui louise weiss cette française
est surnommée la grand-mère de l'europe
retour sur son parcours son long combat
pour l'europe les droits des femmes et
la paix avec la maison de l'europe et le
centre d'information europe direct zone
europe / sensations
louise weiss est né à arras le 25
janvier 1893
en 1914 elle passe l'agrégation qui est
un examen qui permet d'entrer dans la
fonction publique
elle obtient également des diplômes de
littérature des universités de paris et
d'oxford avant que la première guerre
mondiale ne commence pendant la première
guerre mondiale où il va être vivant en
france c est plus spécifiquement en
bretagne afin d'y créer un petit un
petit hôpital militaire afin d'aider les
soldats blessés et d'aider les réfugiés
en 1918 elle lance l'europe nouvelle
un journal qui a vocation pour elle
selon elle de fonder une méthode et un
instrument de travail pour une science
de la paix l'europe nouvelle devient
très rapidement un journal très réputé
et respecté dans le milieu des affaires
internationales we trust considère le
journalisme comme un moyen de faire la
guerre à la guerre des femmes étant
exclu à l'époque de la politique
française elle utilise en fait le
journalisme et notamment les différentes
revues dans lesquels elle travaille afin
d'y publier ces différentes en 1938 elle
convainc le gouvernement français de
créer le comité des réfugiés
ce comité est financé par le
gouvernement français a pour vocation
d'aider les juifs à fuir l'allemagne
lorsque la france passe sous
l'occupation nazie en 1940 la vie de
louise weiss et de sa famille deviennent
de plus en plus compliqué après que son
frère ait échappé à une arrestation en
1943 elle finit par se cacher et
rejoindre la résistance pour inédite et
notamment le journal clandestin la
nouvelle république
après la guerre elle va entreprendre
pendant une décennie de nombreux voyages
dans le monde
à cette occasion elle va rédigé de
nombreux articles sur l'intérêt et
l'importance que le monde occidental et
que l'europe doivent jouer dans le
maintien de la paix au niveau européen
elle va aussi beaucoup insisté sur le
rôle que l'europe peut jouer dans le
maintien des valeurs démocratiques
c'est cette conviction qui va la
conduire à défendre l'europe comme
contrepoids aux états unis et à l'urss
en 1971 elle crée la fondation louise
weiss qui décerne chaque année un prix à
une personne ou une institution qui a le
plus contribué à faire avancer ce
qu'elle appelle la science de la baie et
parmi ces lauréats on peut notamment
citer vaclav havel ou helmut schmidt
surnommée la mamie de l'europe elle est
élue au parlement européen en 1979 à
l'occasion des premières élections
européennes au suffrage universel dure l
eau le suffrage universel direct et en
tant que doyenne de l'assemblée elle y
prononce le discours inaugural
dans son discours elle appelle notamment
tous les européens à s'unir au nom de
leur culture commune et non d'intérêts
économiques partagé après sa mort le
parlement européen donnera son nom à son
siège à strasbourg en hommage au soutien
qu'elle a apporté aux valeurs humaines
tout au long de sa vie place maintenant
à notre invité politique comment tu as
alonso reçoit l'eurodéputé caroline
rousse zone europe
l'invité politique bonjour caroline rose
bonjour vous êtes heureux députés
membres du groupe les verts alliance
libre européenne au sein du parlement
européen
vous êtes membre de la commission d'
enquête sur la protection des animaux
pendant le transport
alors déjà en quelques mots ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler l'objectif de cette
commission d' enquête qui a été laissé
lancée en jeu leur appel en septembre
dernier
oui en fait en septembre on a lancé
cette commission denquête alors c'était
une demande sous l'ancien mandat à
l'origine des verts l'objectif de cette
enquête justement c'est de pouvoir
vérifier les conditions de transport des
animaux vivants et
d'améliorer le texte s'il existe une
réglementation il ya un règlement 1.285
qui va devoir être revu et
et améliorer remis à allant du jour en
fait pour cette législation
il ya quelques mois vous vous êtes rendu
en italie vous étiez en compagnie des
ong de protection animale d'un
vétérinaire et d'autres membres aussi de
la commission donc de cette commission
thomas wet c'est la présidente tilly
messe de camions ont été contrôlés en
provenance de pologne et de roumanie
une des pays de l'union européenne déjà
expliquez moi comment est-ce que vous
procédez comment est ce que vous avez
repéré ces camions alors en fait on a
été invité par justement les ong pour
constater avec les conditions de
transport c'était pour la période de
pâques puisque on a regardé les
transports d'agneau et de moutons ils
ont des points stratégiques on se met au
bord de l'autoroute pour
voir les passages des camions en suis né
camion on regarde s'il ya des
infractions visuellement déjà et ensuite
est une procédure qui est appliquée le
rapport de ces camions vous avez
retrouvé des moutons des agneaux par
centaines dans quelles conditions est ce
que vous avez pu constater qu'ils elles
ont toutes été transportées
alors en fait sur ces camions alors sur
le premier camion par exemple on avait
une attraction sur le temps de transport
le premier camion avait 35 heures de
transport sans s'arrêter sur l'autre
camion il y avait des tétines da
breuvage pour les animaux qui n'étaient
pas adaptés ils étaient adaptés aux
cochons et non pas aux agneaux et
moutons on a vu des animaux qui étaient
non s'ouvrait et puis sur la
réglementation un point 2005
il faut que l'animal puisse rester dans
une position naturelle c'est-à-dire
debout et qu'il est un espace suffisant
sur la tête pour pouvoir bouger et
c'était pas le cas alors finalement ces
deux camions ils ont pu être arrêtés
pour une inspection alors comment cette
dernière s'est ces procès s'est déroulé
comment est ce que vous l'avez signalé
ce que voilà la procédure en fait comme
je disais donc les ong nous ont appelés
ils ont un certain nombre d'informations
donc on se met son bord d'autoroute avec
eux sur des parkings quand le camion
passe mais ensuite camion à plusieurs
voitures quand on voit qu'il ya une
infraction en appel les services de
police qui sont prévenus déjà en amont
j'avoue que la police italienne elle a
été assez réactive à ce niveau là alors
on a un problème c'est un problème
géographique c'est à dire que dès qu'on
suit camion si ça fait pas partie du
secteur de la première police qu'on a
appelés il faut qu'on continue à suivre
le camion donc ça peut durer
closer à suivre le camion la police
arrive se met sur le côté de l'autoroute
double le camion et fait arrêter le
camion à la sortie d'une aire
d'autoroute et on commence inspection
ensuite pour l'un des camions celui qui
était en provenance de roumanie vous
avez trouvez donc à son bord 600 moutons
et agneaux
vous avez constaté différentes
infractions temps de transport trop long
dont vous avez parlé systems d'abb
revanche défectueux quelles sont les
sanctions prévues par la loi contre
toutes ces bavures alors le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya pas eu à part une
amende
c'est tout ce qu'il ya eu et on peut pas
laisser juste une amende aux camions et
laisser repartir le camion alors
a comme je disais tout à l'heure la
police est venue on a arrêté le camion
c'était assez bizarre parce qu'ils ont
allumé les systèmes d'eau tout d'un coup
tous les amis et tous les animaux avait
à boire
alors vous avez 35 heures je l'avais pas
vue sur un des camions ça a été
particulier parce qu'il ya des animaux
qui avait du mal à respirer
il ya eu une inspection police ils ont
regardé les papiers administratifs et
papiers de transport après ils ont
regardé dans le camion
quand ils ont vu qu'il y avait des
animaux qui respirait quasiment plus ils
ont rappelé le service vétérinaire qui
est venu tout de suite et on a continué
une inspection avec eux mais en termes
d'infraction à part une amende c'est
tous cas et puis le camion devait
repartir petit restait 5 50 ou 100 km et
il fallait qu'ils repartent pour que les
animaux arrivent à destination
alors seulement pour l'instant que des
amants en terme de sanction vous qu'est
ce que vous souhaiteriez mois déjà
j'aimerais que
on diminue le transport d'animaux
vivants qu'on privilégie l'abattage sur
place et que déjà le temps de pause et
est important les durées transporte est
important c'est tout ça qu'il faut
revoir au niveau du texte et puis 1 il
ya une aberration dans le texte c'est
que le temps de transport maritime est
considéré comme un temps de repos avec
les roulis sur les bateaux ce qui s'est
passé dans le canal de suez c'est pas
possible ce soit un temps de repos donc
un autre déplacement dans le cadre de
cette commission c'était à l'abattoir de
blancafort dans le cher en france en fin
d'année dernière cet abattoir avait été
pointé du doigt notamment par
l'association l214 et la préfecture pour
ses pratiques envers les animaux vous y
êtes allé en mars dernier vous étiez
accompagné à l'ordre de l'association de
protection animale mais aussi d'un autre
eurodéputé manuel bompard vous avez
notamment publié ensuite une vidéo sur
votre site où on voit un camion arrivait
avec les volailles
est ce que les choses se sont améliorées
pour les dindes et les dindons à la
semaine deux hommes de cette vidéo
à la suite de cette vidéo je dirais que
non puisque de décembre
au moment où je suis allé sur place avec
manuel bompard on a constaté les mêmes
choses au niveau du transport
c'est à dire les cachent toujours aussi
petit les animaux mais ma fille il
n'avait pas su il peut pas se lever et
même à six avait pas de classe au dessus
les ailes dépasse et des cages donc non
c'était absolument pas possible
et en plus on n'a pas pu voir l'abattoir
visiter l'abattoir puisque on vous a
refusé la clé dans l'abattoir on nous a
dit non non c'est bon tout étonné au
norme alors on vous a refusé l'accès en
tant qu'eurodéputé en tant que membre de
cette commission
quels sont vos pouvoirs jusqu'où vous
pouvez aller pour enquêter
par exemple sur sur ce cet abattoir
j'y suis allé en tant que députée
européenne dans de la commission des
transports par la commission des
transports d'animaux vivants j'ai
demandé à rentrer dans l'abattoir pour
voir ce qui ce qui avait été mis aux
normes parce qu'elle est pas mal de
choses qui n'étaient pas aux normes
on nous a refusé l'accès je peux pas
aller au delà de ça on nous a refusé de
rencontrer le vétérinaire de la ddpp qui
étaient sur place et on nous a dit vous
inquiétez pas tout est aux normes ce
qu'on peu ce qu'on a pu voir et
constater c'est les camions qui arrivent
et donc on était à l'extérieur mais si
on peut pas voir on peut exactement
et si l'on sait que je fais pas mal de
missions sur le terrain pour essayer
malgré deux autres thèmes la pêche on
veut dont nous avions déjà reçu dans une
europe
donc sur ce thème puisque vous siéger au
sein de la commission pêche du parlement
européen la justice européenne a
confirmé l'interdiction de la pêche
électrique
la cour de justice européenne a rejeté
un recours des pays bas qui voulait
maintenir cette technique
la décision prendra effet à partir de
juillet est-ce que vous pouvez d'abord
nous décrire cette technique de pêche
elle était très utilisée aux pays bas
c'était une pratique courante mais aussi
à ce qu'elle a utilisé ailleurs elle
était utilisée aussi en france alors moi
j'espère vivement qu'elle s'arrête au
1er juillet parce que les textes c'est
cette une interdiction donc il faut pas
aller au delà
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'on a pu octroyer des licences
ou des dérogations de 10 ans et ça c'est
pas normal
donc ils ont pas obtenu gain de cause
pour l'instant à la technique de pêche
et un chalut équipé d'électrodes qui est
mais je dirais un champ
électromagnétique
du coup tout ce qui est est au fond
remonte en surface avec cette onde de
choc on va dire le problème c'est que il
n'ya pas que les poissons qui remontent
il ya tout ce qui est animaux marins en
général il n'y a pas de sélectivité au
niveau des jeunes élevé juvénile c'est
pareil et au sein de la biodiversité
désastreux ouais alors pourquoi est ce
qu'elle est jugée néfaste sur
l'environnement c'est donc c'est pour
cette raison cette interaction de la
pêche et les cris ou c'est une décision
que vous
vous aviez que vous salue et que votre
combat depuis des seuls sites incombera
depuis des années sur l'amendé mandature
précédente c'était yannick jadot qui
s'occupait du combat de la pêche
électrique je continue son combat et je
vais faire en sorte que ce combat ben
s'arrête avec justement l'obtention de
la fin de cette pêche électrique alors
vous militez aussi pour un meilleur
contrôle des dépêches en général vous
êtes exprimés en ce sens devant le
parlement
le but protéger les populations de
poissons mais aussi les inégalités
envers les pêcheurs c'est votre objectif
oui parce que il ya une injustice et une
grande injustice entre la pêche
industrielle et la petite pêche côtière
si on la répartition des quotas ont dit
oui mais c'est les états membres qui
gère des quotas au sein de chaque état
le problème c'est qu'il ya un article 17
qui répartit les quotas sur des critères
environnementaux sociaux qui n'est pas
appliquée et d'ailleurs sur la
problématique du thon elle n'est pas
appliquée notamment par la france quels
sont les moyens aujourd'hui dont on
dispose dont l'union européenne dispose
pour contrôler la pêche alors déjà faut
faire pression sur les états membres
pour faire appliquer cet article 17
et puis on a obtenu une victoire n'y a
pas très longtemps sur le règlement de
contrôle avec les vms
on a des systèmes de vidéosurveillance
sur des zones marines protégées où il ya
un bip qui aimait quand un bateau va sur
une aire marine protégée va pêcher dans
une aire marine pour de la
vidéosurveillance elle est sur les
bateaux dans les ports sur les bateaux
sur les batteries directement coin merci
beaucoup
en tout cas caroline heureuse d'avoir
été avec nous dans la zone europe pour
parler donc dû des conditions d'animaux
de transport et aussi de la pêche mais
vous êtes heureux débuté les verts
alliance libre européenne et vous êtes
vous également membre de la commission
de la pêche et de la commission d'
enquête sur la protection des animaux
dans le transport merci à vous je vous
emmène en normandie cette semaine pour
découvrir les produits du terroir des
produits qui bénéficient souvent de
label européen
c'est le cas par exemple du neuchâtel ce
fromage a obtenu son appellation
d'origine protégée en 1996 et vous aurez
besoin de neuchâtel notamment pour la
recette du hambourg ger avec grégory
lambert chef du bistro lambert à bernay
dans l'eure
zone europe voyage bienvenue au bistrot
lambert donc je suis grégory lambert
chef et propriétaire avec ma femme
il faut pas l'oublier du bistrot
l'envers donc aujourd'hui je vous
propose est une recette de deux ans
bourget puisqu'en dix ans bourget au
bistrot lambert on est en est 100% local
100% terroir là on va vous faire un an
bourget donc made in normandie
donc vous allez avoir toute la normandie
vraiment concentré dans un seul burger
vous allez avoir donc un bones
artisanale multi grain avec du lin qui
composent pas mal de nos champs je
voudrais faire un petit chatenet de
pommes en guise de en guise de sauce
vous allez avoir un hachés de boeuf donc
pure race normande 200 g lab est donc
c'est pour les gros mangeurs vous allez
avoir une galette de pommes de terre
donc qui vient de la ferme vauquelin au
neubourg et puis vous allez avoir enfin
pour terminer du bacon qui ont la ferme
heavy l'oise donc juste à côté du
neubourg et vous allez avoir pour garnir
le tout une crème de champignons de
neuchâtel et d'andouille histoire de
voile à de rajouter un petit peu de
gourmandises aux burgers donc pour faire
ce en bourget 100 % made in normandie
donc on va commencer par le principal la
viande
donc on est sûr hachés de boeuf race
normande qui vient des éleveurs de la
charentonne on est sur une belle pièce
de 200 210 grammes environ
donc on va commencer par la mettre en
cuisson
voilà avec un peu de sel un peu de poids
et on va la laisser travailler ensuite
donc on prend notre bones artisanale qui
vient du pain de sucre et une
boulangerie pâtisserie qui qui fait tout
nonobs alors on échange
dès que j'ai des idées y fait des tests
et caetera et on essaye de travailler
ensemble donc là on est sur un multi
grain on va ensuite donc à la place du
fameux la fameuse mayonnaise ketchup
là je vous ai fait un petit chatenet de
pommes pour rester dans le terroir donc
comme en effet ce choc n'est de pommes
c'est
des pommes qui sont donc cuites dans le
vinaigre
donc on est sur du vinaigre de cidre
pour être sûr le tout pomme là j'ai
rajouté des raisins vous avez de la
moutarde à l'ancienne et vous avez aussi
du miel pour le côté sucré donc principe
du chutney c'est que vraiment vous ayez
quelque chose des grenouilles qui
apporte à la fois du sucre et de
l'acidité
donc ça c'est le quichotte net il va
vous réveiller les papilles ensuite vous
mettez donc une galette de pommes de
terre dont galettes de pommes de terre
donc de la ferme vauquelin long qui
situe au neubourg pour faire une galette
de pommes de terre rien de plus simple
si vous avez un robot qui rappelait
carottes et c'est à vous le mettez au
robot vous mettez les pommes de terre
aux robots sinon à l'ancienne avec une
bonne rap vous rappeler votre pomme de
terre surtout la l'avait pas puisqu'on
doit garder l'amidon et ensuite vous
façonner des petites galettes voulait
cuisez de chaque côté pendant trois
quatre minutes c'est comme les frites ça
doit être croustillant l'extérieur et
fondeur l'intérieur donc là ça va
rajouter un petit peu de gourmandises à
notre burger pour l'instant on regarde
où on est notre steak
voilà on le marque bien donc après c'est
une question de goût pour le burger moi
je suis plutôt viandards et j'aime la
viande saignante
après c'est une viande de qualité donc
faudrait pas aller plus loin que le rosé
pour regarder vraiment tout là toute la
saveur de la viande
donc on est sûr de la race normande
comme tout ce qui agrémente notre burger
aujourd'hui donc pendant que la viande
est toujours en train de cuire je vous
demandais d'approcher ce qui va être on
va dire une des pièces maîtresses de ce
burger
je ne sais pas s'il avoue loyer via la
caméra vous n'avez pas les odeurs mais
nous on les a c'est une crème de
neuchâtel cidre et champignons qui va
venir garnir le dessus de notre steak
qui va venir enrobé vraiment où le
burger donc là on a vraiment tout là
toute la normandie vraiment condensé
dans un seul produit
ça va venir nappes et où le burger pour
avoir quelque chose vraiment très très
gourmand donc ensuite on va rajouter le
bacon que j'ai préalablement passé à la
plancha donc qui vient de l'affirmer
lilloise
donc on est toujours sur une viande de
porc et s'agit origines tiens ils sont
élevés vraiment dans le respect du
bien-être de l'animal pas
d'antibiotiques pas de conservateurs pas
d'additif on est vraiment sur un très
très bon produit et on est sur du local
je le répète une fois de plus c'est
vraiment très très important
le fameux steak de 200 grammes convient
disposés sur ces petites galettes de
pommes de terre
ensuite donc le bacon grillé
et pour terminer on va napper le burger
avec une crème d'andouille cidre pour
l'évêque qui va venir
enrobé
a le regard
na na plus faux que ça dégouline
hamburger c'est comme ça un petit pic de
présentation pour maintenir la bête
voilà donc le hambourg ger made in
normandie donc 100% local 100% terroir
donc avec un bundle tigres n o donc
artisanale un petit chatenet de pommes
une galette de pommes de terre ail haché
de boeuf race normande 200 210 g
la bête bacon grillé de la ferme heavy
l'oise et puis on termine le tout pour
le côté gourmand avec une crème de
neuchâtel champignons cidre et andouille
qui vient recouvrir
voilà ce burger avec bien évidemment les
frites maison du bistrot au paprika et
pour se donner un peu de bonne
conscience un peu de coleslaw avec des
petites lamelles de pommes légèrement
citronné les expressions populaires être
très connu les français disent être
connu comme le loup blanc les portugais
eux disent être plus connu que le pape
que dit-on ailleurs regardez zone europe
expression d'ici et d'ailleurs
au portugal en dix sept maicon cidco
pape
ce qui signifie être plus connu que le
var en italie on dit est ce l écono
choteau comme elle l'est le bab et
tonique à cela signifie être connus
comme l'herbe lab et one
en espagne on dit seulement qu non c'est
là qu'est la capitale se voir être plus
connu quelques pépites à dans son
quartier zone europe s'est terminée
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site
internet et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv 78 rendez
vous la semaine prochaine
très bonne soirée sous une robe sûr
sensation